foreign
[Music]
sir did you hear me initiate the launch
D minus five minutes to launch Auto
sequence has been initiated
[Music]
thank you
oh Jesus you you can take this guy right
what does that mean what are our chances
[Music]
oh [__] it let's go save the planet
Venom get in a rocket no we won't let
you destroy this world can't die
[Music]
I have strong host
I'm not strong enough
foreign
[Music]
what happened
oh
my God
[Music]
told you I can fight I'll clean
it too late
this is the next stage
you talk too much
[Music]
you are nothing
thank you
[Music]
um
greater have a nice life
[Music]
goodbye
there you are death to you father no not
you father
you father oh [__]
this is much worse than I thought that
is a red one oh red one we should leave
immediately I think we'll get over it we
never like that anyway so let's go now
congratulations to the happy couple we
are leaving Eddie
I'll be right with you all right
I need to come out right now because I
am feeling super super vulnerable right
here Brooks just like you not for long
Eddie over here
you need to come out right now and I
will let you eat everybody you can eat
them all apart from him in the robe you
cannot eat him promise
thank you
oh
foreign
[Music]
that's the spirit I mean us we are going
to die
[Music]
thank you
Environ sound except without the sound
three years
[Music]
[__]
ER
you know how I Spent My Endless days
I spent them thinking about how you only
told one side of the story
you didn't write about the part where
Cletus was abused my mommy daddy and
Granny
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
you never asked yourself why
wow bad journalism
wow Happy Days
[Applause]
I'm not crazy man
but I am a finch for one
you're going to watch her die
[Applause]
[Music]
they're not symbiotic
shut up
you're not a match
that's right we are
together we are
the legal protector
[Music]
thank you
let there be courage
oh
my God
I gotcha okay
[Music]
everyone
father one of us must die
we need fire
or sound
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
yourself
oh
you have been a serious pain in the ass
well you know I aim to please
[Music]
eyes
so many snacks so little time
[Music]
thank you
is peaceful up here I'm not very good
with Heights
The World Is Not So Ugly after all
I'm almost sorry to see you then what
does that mean
s
I got us
oh
again
gotta get me killed you died I die yeah
you could always just sit my carcass and
exchange it for another one whenever you
need why would I do that you are far too
good of a match to throw away so soon
plus I'm starting to like you you and I
are not so different thank you
okay
here's your evidence
jump
foreign
[Music]
on the ground now
guys you you do not want to do this
trust me
all right how about your way
everybody too
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign